mercedes is with us in toronto canada hi
mercedes welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call well
sure what's up
um i'm currently on maternity leave
until february
and i want to ask how to
ask my husband to be able to kind of be
a stay-home mom
i don't really feel like i want to go
back to work i feel like i really want
to
spend time raising our little one cool
what a great goal
so does he make enough money for you to
live on
uh yeah like he makes about 9.75
what's that mean oh uh like 975
000. 975 000
a year yeah okay
i think you could probably freaking
struggle through
it's not so much the finances that it as
it is i think he has a worry that
i'll never go back to work so
like i don't know i think because his
mom
worked like three jobs so
i know he makes 975 000
i know mercedes when you were working
how much did you make
about 90. okay nice income yeah
except that we're comparing it to his
right and how many kids do you have
just one just okay okay here's the deal
sharon ramsey went home to be a
full-time mom
when our first daughter was born 34
years ago
yeah she has never worked in the
workplace since
uh she is engaged in a lot of uh
ministry boards
she sits on hospital boards she uh is
engaged in being
a full-time meme to six grandbabies
she raised three wonderful children
i call that an incredible career
i do too
okay i just don't know how to get my
husband on the same page
it's a matter it's going to be sitting
down and talking to him from the heart
i mean just point blank i mean hey it's
not like you guys need the money this is
why this is so flabbergasting yeah
so i know why why does he go do all of
that if it's not so that your family can
do what they want to do
i know like i just don't see the point
in paying like a nanny
no
and not since you don't want to okay
yeah so if you want to be outside the
home and have a career and that's your
aspiration and you want to do that then
no shame on that either
absolutely but uh but this idea that
somehow motherhood
is full-time motherhood is not a uh is
somehow
to be shamed or to be looked down upon
is absolute bs
well and i think mercedes that's where
you've got to talk to him and lead with
the heart
and talk about how you are you wanting
to work but you're wanting to work
with your kid it doesn't make you a
freaking second-class citizen
no not at all i know
but i guess i kind of feel that way and
i don't know whether it's more
but you know we call that mom we call
that mom guilt
yeah sure christy wright talks about
that a lot mom moms can't win because if
they work they're guilty and if they
don't work they're guilty
i know it's like mom like like guilt is
built into the whole program or
something i don't know what it is but
how long have you all been married
mercedes uh
only a year and a half yeah what's a boy
child do for a living he's been together
about seven
um he's an investment advisor i guess he
is the writer
okay okay wow it's so impressive he's
doing so well
i don't know i i i think that um
number one i just want to give you uh
encouragement and say hey this is not
crazy it's not irresponsible
as a matter of fact it is a high dignity
position
worthy of i mean someone was
abraham lincoln's mother someone was
billy graham's mother
someone was you know and these are high
call this is a high
calling and uh so
someone was martin luther king jr's
mother i mean
this is a high calling and uh it has
dignity it has value it is worth
equivalent to anything you could do in
the workplace
no shame no guilt and should be no
hesitation
financially or economically i agree and
mercedes i'm going to tell you this
don't go into this thinking this is a
one-time conversation
that you're gonna sway him or get him
this is going to be a series of
conversations but i want you to lead
with your heart
don't try to go factual don't go any of
that just what your heart wants
and then what happens is it boils down
to he has an opinion
and you have an opinion and now you got
to begin to work through this and you
may have to reach out to your pastor
or to a therapist and go have this
conversation but if you don't stand
for it and show you're serious about it
then he's not going to believe you yeah
just turn off the television take his
phone away from him set the baby in his
lap and point at the baby and say what's
more important than that
or take off for about a week let him
handle it let him handle it
he will find you honey i'm gonna tell
you right now
your value just went i told sharon
years ago i said if you leave i'm coming
with you
if you decide you're gonna run off i'm
coming too
oh i was expecting for her to say that
that that
she made the majority of the money and
you know and it was a financial
number that is